you guys already talked about Justin
Bieber all right you want to talk about
it more yeah I randomly called out well
not that we know why Cano I'm Cruz out
of all that's okay we don't know yet
yeah I didn't know that huh
Bieber call out you didn't see this be
recall that wants to ask Dana white to
fight him in the Octagon I got my money
on Tom Cruise Tom sure a lot of people
do he's not wrestling he wrestled Tom
tree high school oh yeah okay they
wanted it he wanted to go to college
wrestling well I don't give I wouldn't
consider him wrestler but I'm just
saying he beat the [ __ ] adjusted me
correct
Scientology crazy there's all zones and
on sick much stronger than Justin Bieber
much bigger and stronger yeah I don't
know as much I won't call Tom Cruise
thick either he's thick I've spent time
with him um yeah I've seen him very wide
oh yeah
he's very powerful I'm not kidding I
just think I don't know about the sheer
numbers I think you'd beat the [ __ ] a
beaver though he's crazy does although
it's fun to fight the Octagon Tom if you
don't take this fight you scared you're
scared and you smell your lungs yeah why
oh that's a big pity of mine you'll
never live down who's willing to put on
but why do we have any idea no one knows
why that's right that's why the headline
says Twitter's confused his head you
know what bums me out then Connors again
I'll fight yes wall bears the same card
I was like ah god I feel sick
why is this happening back when Mark
Wahlberg was marking mark I
I'd have still slaps he gears off him
and took my UFC shares back alright it's
very weird it's super random what people
are saying obviously that's why be white
like did Tom Cruise do some to Bieber
that's the thing going to hose if it's
also at Bieber's age it's where to call
a Tom Cruise ooh
six yeah they said that Bieber is also
like recently taking a hiatus from music
to work on himself and then this
happened just do things you go crazy
mmm he's choking it's just really really
right a terrible joke though if you're
gonna call somebody out you see Logan
Paul's okay let's do it be here if you
want someone young
do it because way too big way too strong
it's so stir all that's just yet so
strange
yeah but I want to know what Tom Cruise
dead
well if Tom Cruise like yeah I [ __ ]
this girl will do when we do Scientology
shut Scientology I I would 100% take Tom
Cruise everyone saying that even odd
shark Tom Cruise is one intense
[ __ ] right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue Oh what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]